eating isn't taken for granted when
you're a child with 12 severe food
allergies six of which a
life-threatening dairy and all forms of
se include - cheese cream your milk your
ice cream all forms of nuts all forms of
tree nut seeds tomato Kiwi peppers
citrus dust cats dogs pollen
excruciating eczema has been one of the
most debilitating effects here just a
few weeks old
rashes thought to have been triggered by
Dairy in Natalie's breast milk he was
bright red he was passed see there was
blood his skin didn't look clear at any
point at all you would pick him up in
the morning and it looked like a murder
being committed in his Moses basket it
was absolutely horrific and it doesn't
matter how many times we went to the
doctors they would just say oh it's just
baby eczema or it's just colic or it's
just a bit of reflux so get over it but
deep down you know as mum there's a lot
more going on there can't be too many
four-year-olds who carry an emergency
medical kit but considering half of all
children in the UK now have some kind of
allergy perhaps it's not too surprising
one of the world's leading specialists
is among those who say healthcare
provision hasn't been able to keep pace
with the scale of the allergy epidemic
looking at peanut allergy alone this has
doubled over the last two decades so
just under 3% of children in the UK and
North America Australasia are now
affected by peanut allergy so this has
been a rapid rise they are now 1 in 30
that's 1 in every classroom affected by
peanut allergy and I'm sure you can
remember back to your own school days
where very few children were affected in
an entire school the number of people
being hospitalized with severe allergic
reactions has gone up by 615 percent in
the last 20 years this little wonder the
charity allergy UK says it's getting
more calls from people looking for help
and advice there are pockets in the
country where the provision is
so virtually non-existence is probably
the best way I can put it we have a
helpline and parents that come through
to our helpline sometimes are desperate
for help for their children they just
don't know where to go
nothing gets Callum down though
especially when he's eating his mom's
cooking and for parents trying to get
the right help for their child Nathalie
has this fight trust your instinct
believe in what you are saying even if
no one else is do your food diary start
from the morning all the way through
tonight what you feed them what the
nappies look like and please listen to
mums
mums know their children Gemma Morris
Tiny's